[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the second
video on pawn end game principles in the
first video we started our journey
toward endgame mastery by taking a deep
dive into past pawns we explored what
past pawns are how to use them how to
create them
and we categorized and characterized
several different very important types
of past pawns make sure to watch that
video if you haven't already because as
i discussed beforehand these videos will
build on top of each other the
information and knowledge gained in one
video will be used directly in the next
and so on and so forth and if i've
structured it properly then uh having
watched the videos in order i think
you'll find that you get quite excited
and uh
that you see kind of the positive uh
reinforcement of knowing a lot of stuff
and a lot of jargon and a lot of terms
and ideas that you previously didn't
know
but it's very important that you watch
the videos in order
because i'll be using and referring to a
lot of these concepts without explaining
them again
now let's say that both sides have
passed pawns or a pass pawn which is
what frequently happens well what do you
do with pass bombs will you try to
promote them and generally make a queen
and there is a very particular kind of
situation a very exciting situation that
occurs when both sides are furiously
trying to be the first to promote to a
queen
the sides have understood that neither
can stop the opposing sides past pawn
and so the only
remaining thing to do is to try to make
sure that your pawn promotes faster than
your opponent's pawn and that situation
is of course called a pawn race and pawn
races are the subject of
this video now pawn races occur quite
frequently in pawn end games they
frequently are the sort of concluding
stage to pawn end games and the winner
of the pawn race uh consequently uh ends
up most of the time the winner of the
game and we'll discuss what it even
means to win a pawn race of course
that's
where the nuance and the complexity sets
in
now just like past pawns pawn races
might seem to be a very intuitive and
self-explanatory concept right you just
push your pawn toward promotion whatever
happens happens if you're slower you're
slower if you're faster faster what is
there to talk about well as it turns out
there is a lot to talk about so let's
strap ourselves in let's dive into uh
the art of winning a pawn race okay
so
uh
before we
delve into the sort of the meat of the
video let's talk definition once again
now when you hear the term pawn race
uh the mental reference that at least
comes to my mind is an end game of this
sort right you can shift the pawns
around something like this right this is
a classic uh pawn race which has a
sort of in
prelude right where the kings walk
toward the pawns that they want to
capture they capture them that's how you
create the passer then the kings step
away and then the pawns march forward
and you know may the faster pawn prevail
so pawn races are among the
very often are among the easiest
sequences to calculate and in fact they
are a very good way to work on your
visualization your ability to visualize
uh
variations in your head so throughout
this video i
highly encourage you uh to follow along
with me as i
calculate using arrows i will often
calculate without moving the pieces and
then i'll move the pieces afterward but
if you're maybe a little bit newer to
chess or uh you you prefer not to do the
visualization you can absolutely have a
board nearby and set these positions up
on a board and move the pieces nothing
wrong with that at all
okay so let's assume that it's white to
move in this position white is going
straight up black is going down
what happens well
both sides have nothing better to do
than to go and take each of the response
we have king c4 king f5 king takes b4
king g4
the king steps away somewhere let's say
king c5
king takes h4 b4
black's king steps away let's say to g4
b5 h4 b6 h3 b7 h2 b8
and h1 and it appears that the queens
are made simultaneously and the game
ends in a draw so the outcome of this
particular pawn race is a draw even
though white is the first to take black
spawn so already you can see a little
bit of
uh counter-intuitiveness shall we say
and the white seems to take the pawn
first and yet the pawns promote at the
same time and that is of course because
black's pawn is already further advanced
to begin with so let's make the moves on
the board and confirm
our conclusion
okay so the king steps away
b4 black's king steps away b5 h4 b6 and
i know you might think i did something
wrong there now i deliberately stepped
into the checking path of white's pawn
right white promoted with check the
funny thing is this actually still
happens to be a draw because of king g2
and as i said in the previous video this
is another theoretical end game that
perhaps some of you know this is a draw
because white cannot make progress here
this will probably be the subject of a
future video but for now you can take my
word for it it's a bit outside the scope
of what we're talking about but you can
already see some complexity developing
here because you can't just step away
anywhere maybe in this case it's a draw
but in other cases you aren't
best advised to step away onto a square
that allows your opponent to promote
check and so the most prudent move is
definitely king g4 king g5 and now you
get a classic sort of simultaneous
promotion
and uh there is nothing that white can
do other than essentially take the draw
or give a series of meaningless checks
so that's one type of pawn race we can
shift the pawns around a little bit we
can get a different type of pawn race
and this is where as i said this is
where we start exploring a little bit of
the new ones because
the winner of a pawn race
what defines like how do you know who
wins upon race well first of all it has
to do with mathematical factors who is
closer to
uh to the enemy pawn and if you're the
same distance away from the enemy pawn
then it matters
the geometry matters tremendously
because very often you will promote and
uh if you've seen any pawn races you're
familiar with the situation this is one
of the most
uh typical
situations that just sort of epitomizes
the pawn race where you promote and you
simultaneously stop your opponent from
promoting and we'll we'll see more
examples of this let's again practice
our visualization and calculate out the
spawn race it's white to play king b5
king g4 king takes pawn king takes pawn
king steps away to b6 black's king steps
away to g3 a5 h4 a6 h3 a7 h2 looks like
simultaneous promotion but no white
plays a it equals queen and black cannot
promote because from a8 the queen guards
blacks promotion square let's make the
moves on the board
and you will see
that this is exactly
what happens h3 a7 h2 a8 queen
and that's it now might say wait a
minute didn't i just say that this was a
draw well there is one very important
caveat here the cavity is that black's
king previously was on g2 and it could
move toward g1 here the king is unable
to reach g1 in time and because of that
white brings the queen back to h1
blockading the pawn and this of course
is a very easy win as white just brings
the king back toward the black pawn
eventually pushing the king away from
the pawn
so this is
what i think comes to mind when you hear
the term pawn race something like this
you walk toward the enemy pawn you
capture you step aside with your king
and then you run your pawn up the board
and what happens happens right what is
so complicated about that well again as
it turns out there is a lot that's
complicated about that and when you put
pawn races in context right when you put
them into the actual context of a rich
pawn end game you see that there are
actually so many pitfalls to avoid and
so many ways in which skill actually
plays a role in who wins upon race
paradoxically enough and the way that i
want to structure this video is in the
form of five rules
five rules of pawn races rules that if
you follow to the letter and if you
follow properly will greatly maximize
your chances of emerging from a pawn
race unscathed and maximizing your
chances often of swindling your opponent
if your opponent isn't familiar with
these rules and violates them you will
often be able to turn a pawn race around
one that you were supposed to lose or
even tie might
turn out to be a win or if you're
supposed to lose it into a draw without
further ado let's go rule by rule let's
discuss discuss these rules and every
rule will have an example associated
with it and i'm very excited about this
video because i really really like these
examples i feel like pawn races are very
fun in general but the examples you're
about to see they're not very well known
but i think they really bring out the
beauty
of pawn end games
okay let's begin with rule number one
and if i've done this correctly it
should display on the screen right about
now
rule number one and we will work sort of
in direct chronological order we start
from the beginning of the pawn race and
each rule kind of concerns a step of the
pawn race if that makes sense the first
rule concerns the process of actually
eliminating
the pawn you might remember from the
previous video the king capture method
right in order to make a passed pawn and
the rule is do not capture unnecessary
pawns
now i know you have a lot of what do you
what do you mean unnecessary well that's
why we have the example
so the funny story behind this game is
it was played in the world youth chess
championship under 14 in 2008 in vietnam
i played in that tournament i played in
the under under 14 section
and uh i was curious and i tracked down
my board number and their board number
and it turns out that i was sitting
literally three boards away from uh
let's untie and i'm probably miss
pronouncing that in daniel ebeling who
is now i think a very strong fide master
or international master
um so you know such a small world and
now of course i'm showing their game
uh in a youtube video and of course i i
the reason i found this game isn't
because i remembered it it's because i
did a chess-based search and this game
came up
so it is black to play and
perhaps you can pause the video for a
little while and
first of all sort of adjust your eyes to
what's going on do you see how the pawn
race begins and once you identify what
the race is all about see if you can
calculate it out and uh figure out who
wins the pawn race i'll give you a
couple of moments here as i said my
coffee
okay
well hopefully you were able to
uh identify that the the sort of
skeleton of the pawn race is that black
is going to go after the h pawn
and white is going to go after the a
pawn because this is the a5 pawn is
white's most far advanced uh perspective
passer
so that's exactly what happens black
plays king f5 white plays king c5 and
here they go black plays king g4 and
this moment is where rule one applies
and rule one is perhaps the simplest and
most intuitive rule
very importantly and i've seen a lot of
people do this this is why i'm
introducing this rule
there's this automatic instinct to
capture as many puns as you can but as i
said in the
uh inspirational video this is not
pac-man okay pawn end games are not
pac-man they're the opposite of pac-man
and you often want to avoid pawns that
you can capture in order to capture the
one pawn that you need to capture what
happens if you take on c6 if you make
this detour what happens is that white
actually loses the game watch this king
takes h4 king b6 king g3
okay now you have to take a6 black plays
h4
and
okay losing the game that was a lie
white does have a miracle draw here i
will show you in a moment but if you
follow the kind of uh conventional path
and then you move your king away or you
take b5
you see that this is exactly the
scenario that we just saw in the second
the second illustration where black
promotes and simultaneously stops white
from promoting and wins the game easily
now the funny thing is white can still
draw the game in this position with a
pawn breakthrough the move c3 c4
not an easy move to play here's the
point if black plays bc
then we have simultaneous promotion
white promotes with check and white is
out of the woods this is a draw
and if black pushes the age pawn instead
which seems to win the game because it's
not hard to establish that uh that black
promotes first but
this is
a notion that we will explore in
subsequent videos these are very complex
pawn races where you get a situation
like this how do you evaluate this white
plays b7
now
if you know anything about these types
of end games they're generally winning
for black unless you have an a or a c
pawn but in this particular instance
it's a draw these other two pawns
provide just enough of a pawn cover to
restrict the queen's checking ability
and the queen is unable to make progress
so if you play king c's queen c7 white
is king eight without these pawns black
has this check on a5 which forces the
king underneath the pawn and then black
is able to move uh the king closer and
closer in this case it's a drop but
that's completely beside the point
because if white does not stop to take
this unnecessary pawn and
uh let's hentai did not
stop to take the unnecessary pawn white
wins quite easily by keeping the spawn
on c6 white is actually
allowing himself to win the pawn race
because after black promotes this pawn
will serve as a huge obstruction it will
obstruct the queen's ability uh to
control the a8 square allowing white to
promote now there's also a pitfall here
that uh hopefully you were able to avoid
let's watch king takes h4 king a6 king
g3 king steps toward b6 stepping on
uh a good square h4 a6 we'll get to that
later in a subsequent role
a7 h2 a8 h1
and you might say
wait a second but the queen's promoted
at the same time but if you calculate
just one move ahead
after queen takes c6 it it's quite clear
that white wins the game because white
wins one pawn and there is no way for
black to defend the other pawn as well
and queen in two versus queen is a very
very elementary win and white won the
game in about 15 moves
so a i think a really precise
application of the first rule which is
that
the most important thing in pawn races
uh is efficiency most of the time and
the vast majority of the time you cannot
afford to make detours to capture
unnecessary puns and often capturing
them actually hurts you
by opening up a diagonal that can allow
your opponent's queen
to prevent you from promoting one last
thing i'll say about this example just
to tease you a little bit
those with a keen tactical eye end game
i might have noticed that black doesn't
actually have to play king of five black
and play king d6 this looks like a draw
it is not a draw white is still winning
here which may sound crazy because the
kings just seem to be dancing around but
i won't tell you how it wins here you
will have to wait until our video
our video until my video on um
on zugsvang and i haven't decided
exactly how to title it basically the
video will be about using your king
and this will be a couple of videos down
the line and i will return to this
example and analyze why king d6 loses
so rule one do not capture unnecessary
pawns
now let us get to rule 2 and rule 2
might actually be the most important
rule of all let me
in a very high tech manner i'm going to
project
rule 2 on the screen here
there we go and rule two now i'm getting
ocd i need to extend this a little bit
there we go
do not step away into the checking zone
of your opponent's passer
um now hopefully this is pretty
self-explanatory what i mean by that is
that when you capture the pawn
that moment when you step aside with
your king is actually crucially
important and i see so many mistakes
even by very strong players where you
just sort of absent my little absent
mightily put your king just about
anywhere
and you end up walking into a check when
i say checking zone what i mean by that
is
uh
the spot
which is on the diagonal that your
opponent's newly minted queen is going
to be checking on right so whichever
pass spawn your opponent has you draw
the line down
uh you see what diagonal the newly you
know the new queen controls and you make
sure not to put your king on that
diagonal because obviously allowing your
opponent to promote check can be
absolutely devastating and a very simple
illustration of that is uh found in this
example so it's white to play
again pause the video calculate the pawn
race and see if you can figure out where
white should put the the king in order
to abide by rule two
okay
so the start of the pawn race is
self-explanatory king takes safe working
takes f4 now i think a lot of people
would sort of there's this tendency
right there's this temptation almost to
bring the king forward it's an end game
so i feel like your your uh kind of
basic neurons are firing in the
direction of pushing your king upward
and yet this is a fatal mistake because
you identify the checking zone and the
checking zone is this diagonal and we
put our king exactly in the wrong spot
either king b4 or king b3 both moves
draw obviously not king a5 because then
you're not actually getting the king
away from
the a file so after king b5 king e5 um
or i apologize king king 5 is bad
because the white king can actually stop
the pawn a better is to play for example
king e3
white pushes black pushes and you know
the drill a7 darn it black promotes with
check and the king is nowhere near b8 so
black's queen is able to return
t to win the game anywhere else is fine
king b3
a4 excuse me f4
a5 f3 and now you're not in the checking
zone and both sides promote the game
ends peacefully so that was a very
simple illustration but of course things
uh can get quite a bit trickier okay let
me rewind that i apologize for that
things can get quite a bit trickier and
this very obscure game between two
spanish players uh their ratings weren't
recorded in chess base but my guess is
that they're approximately uh 16 1700
and so many instructive moments can be
found in games between club players and
again i don't mean this in a demeaning
way to the contrary i feel like often in
chess literature uh
you know grandmaster games are super
important but uh games of club players
regular players masters are very
underexplored so that's one of those
things i'm going to try to try to do
throughout this video series is explore
unknown games uh played between just
sort of regular players
uh as well as well as games by the the
ultimate masters and endgame legends
okay
so in this position it is black to play
and black made the move g6 to g5
now at first blush you might think well
this isn't even a pawn race right
because white has a passport on the c
pawn black doesn't and you might say
well black doesn't even have a way to
create a pass pawn if you watch the
previous video you'll you'll see that
the d-pawn is not a passer right d3 e
takes d3 so what's so hard about this y
just pushes the pawn forward to
promotion
but pause the video for a moment and
figure out why that's not correct does
black in fact have a way to create a
past pawn and if so how
time for more water for me
okay
so
this kind of gets into the concept of
pawn breakthroughs which again is the
subject of the next video
uh but hopefully you were able to figure
out that black played g5 not just
because he wanted to push upon but
because black wants to play f4
and then push either the d-pawn or the
f-pawn in order to make the other pawn
of passover so for example let's make
some random moves a3 a4 whatever
black wants to play f3
e takes f3 d3 or alternatively black can
play d3 forcing this pawn off of e2 and
then f3 a very simple kind of pawn
breakthrough and you'll see so many of
these in the next video so this is in
fact a pawn race that may camouflage
uh
under a sort of non-pawn race and may
seem completely winning for white but
amazingly white is in actually quite a
bit of danger and precise play is
required
so now you might wonder well what does
this have to do with rule number two
because if you think about this for a
second
white's king could seem to move just
about anywhere and not be in the
checking zone of either the d or the f
pawn oop sorry about that of either the
d or the f font and yet there's quite a
bit going on under the surface so pause
the video and try your best to calculate
this out and see how you can follow rule
two and for extra credit see if you can
figure out what very very bad move white
played which directly violated rule two
and led to tragedy
okay so
first and foremost this isn't exactly a
rule but just a good practice in a
situation like this you want to make the
most uh necessary
moves first now what do i mean by
necessary moves you know for a fact that
you're going to push this pawn to c5
right so what white should have done
regardless of where he brought the king
is to play c5 first and only after f4 to
decide where he wanted to put the king
okay
because what i did is already set
himself up for failure
by moving the king first and had white
made a move maybe the visualization task
would have gotten a little bit easier
white instead played the move king d7
which actually to me
looks very very natural right you get
the kingford you stop the black king
from going backward looks completely
normal but hopefully you were able to
see why this is actually a decisive
mistake watch this f4
okay c5
and black
which move does he play does he play d3
or does he play f3
well the king hopefully you were able to
see is in fact in the checking zone of a
queen that could be promoted on d1 that
queen would be checking the black ink
directly so black plays the move f4 f3
and clearly this was overlooked by white
white thought i could just take the pawn
and we promote at the same time but no
you don't black promotes with check and
wins the game quite easily because the
king is so close to this pawn
now in the game white had nothing better
than to make the move c6
but now checking zone number two
checking zone can be extended to not
only mean
not only mean directly a check but also
to a situation where the queen can
skewer the other king and queen a
situation that we are about to see a lot
of uh through the prism of the next rule
but in this case
you can imagine that after white
promotes to a queen there is going to be
a potentially skewerable situation the
king and the queen are going to be the
same diagonal
now from where
would black's queen black's new queen be
able to exploit that skewer well there's
a choice here right you can play f takes
e2 or f2 and using rule 1 you know that
you shouldn't play after c2 just because
it's a pawn this position is about so
much more than that and in fact the only
correct move is f2
c7 f1 queen c8 queen now queen f5 check
is good black blade queen h3 check which
is also good
now this doesn't win white's queen this
only leads to a trade and hilariously we
now have another pawn race but this one
is completely lopsided black has managed
to keep one of his prospective passers
and now he uses the king capture method
to approach white spawn capture it now
this is a pretty pathetic pawn race it's
funny white still tries he plays b4 you
know that's like a ferrari racing
against a a reliant robin and the wheels
are coming off and black promotes with
room to spare and won the game in about
10 moves and so tragedy struck here
because white didn't put enough thought
into where to step aside with the king
now what would have been correct well
correct would have been to start with
the move c5
and after f4 why can play g takes f4
that doesn't really impact the position
but the only correct square is actually
b7 might seem counter-intuitive but this
is the only way to get the king away
from the checking zone of both of these
pawns for instance after f3 now white
can play e takes f3 and although white
promotes second this is still
simultaneous promotion white promotes
black promoter black promotes white
promotes white reaches a winning queen
end game why is this winning well
currently white is up a pawn
and he's gonna be up up a lot more pawns
black can take f3 but white takes a6
white then takes a7 this is very similar
to the example we looked at in rule one
where upon race results in a winning
queen end game very common uh scenario
now this still will take a lot of work
but it's very very clear that white is
that white is winning
so
i really like this example because it's
sort of right it shows that not
everything is as easy as just sort of
seeing oh well does black promote with
check no here you have to do a lot of
work you have to understand that first
of all black is capable of creating a
pass pawn second of all you have to
consider two different checking zones
the checking zone of the d-pawn is what
kills white in the event uh in the event
that white takes and the checking zone
of the f-pawn is what destroys white uh
and leads to his demise in the event of
c6 so kind of a nice multifaceted
example and that
brings us then to rule three so do not
step away into the checking zone of your
opponent's passer is rule two
okay again using my super high tech
method
projecting onto the screen rule three
okay
so rule three says that simultaneous
promotion that is you promote then your
opponent promotes or vice versa
does not equal draw very common
misconception a lot of players just kind
of assume when they're calculating i
make a queen my opponent makes a
contract now as we've already seen and
hopefully you're already able to
understand that's completely not the
case because very often simultaneous
promotion just leads to a
complicated queen end game but more
common are situations where simultaneous
promotion
immediately allows the side that
promotes first or that promotes with
check so you can promote second
technically but if you promote with
check that's basically like promoting
first so the side that promotes first
has a tremendous amount of power and in
many cases can immediately either
deliver checkmate or
win the opposing queen through a skewer
and this position is a very simple and
this situation occurs very frequently a
great illustration of rule three what
happens it's white to play
you know the drill pause the video see
if you can calculate this out until the
end and most of you i know are probably
familiar with this type of example so
you know the drill
okay so there's not much to calculate
here once again just to practice
visualization i'm going to make these
moves with arrows and then and only then
am i going to execute them on the board
so g4 a5
g5 a4 g6 a3 g7 a2 neither king is in the
checking zone of the opposing pawn g8
queen a1 queen
and now hopefully you were able to see
that the queen and the king are on
adjacent
uh files and the white king is uh in
opposition to the black king which means
the black king has no uh accessible
squares in the c file and that means it
can be pushed away
onto the a file with queen b8 check and
then skewered with queen aa check now we
can play these moves very quickly g5a4
g6a3 2782 blah blah blah queen b8 check
and that is it queen aa check and the
black queen is lost so this was a very
simple illustration a slightly more
involved illustration is yielded by this
position which some of you movie buffs
might recognize this is the final scene
in my favorite chess movie searching for
bobby fisher when josh waits again the
movie is not about bobby fischer spoiler
when josh waitzkin is facing off against
jonathan poe in that all-important
championship game
and uh this position was actually
designed i think by grandmasters except
even they made a cool mistake which i'll
tell you about in a second
essentially here is black to play and
josh initiates this long combination he
offers a draw to be kind uh his opponent
thinks that he's winning because his
pawn is further advanced and they play
it out rook takes knight check knight d7
check so this wins white's rook back now
the hilarious thing is in this position
a little known fact white can actually
still draw the game
by pushing the pawn to h5 this is a
little outside the scope of the video
and we're already about 30 minutes in so
i'll be quick
you can take my word for it but knights
are terrible at stopping past spawns
this will be a subject of a video way
down the line
and essentially white draws by
continually chasing the snide around and
not allowing it to
stabilize and stop the pawn but instead
of course in the movie he takes the
knight immediately thinking i'm
promoting first and he's right white
does promote first but hopefully you're
able to see what's going on the king is
in the checking zone of the black queen
and so is the white queen and after they
both promote it turns out that black
promotes and
simultaneously skewers white's queen on
h8 josh wins the game and he wins of
course the whole championship so rule
three conceptually speaking is is
is simple right you just have to not
assume that just because both players
end up with queens that somehow means
the pawn race has ended in a tie you
have to try to keep calculating and in
particular you have to look at a skewer
possibilities and b the possibility to
uh force another queen trade which
because of the positioning of your king
uh could lead to a subsequently winning
pawn end game um or queen end game and
those more involved situations uh we
will examine in in further videos when
we start putting putting things together
so that ladies and gentlemen is rule
three and now let us get to
rule four
okay and don't worry i won't block the
names of the players
okay i think we're good
and rule four says use your king to
force the enemy king into the checking
zone or to prevent the enemy king from
stopping your pawn and the reason i
combine those things is that rule 4
essentially concerns how you should use
your own king in a pawn race
and
this already sort of combats the
misconception that pawn races never
involve the king that's absolutely not
true in fact the king often plays a
critical role in helping you win a pawn
race and i think this is one of my
favorite examples of that let's flip the
board we'll be facing it from black's
perspective my great friend vladimir
fedosev uh super strong grandmaster is
facing timur roger bob this is from a
classical tournament uh todd of steel
now it's black to play
take a second and and acquaint yourself
with the position it may seem at first
sight that white is winning
white's about to take g6 and promote
that f pawn but from the previous video
and from my sort of sneak preview and to
pawn breakthroughs you should
immediately be able to tell that black
will not go gentle into that good knight
black has a pawn majority which means
with the move b5 black can create a pass
pawn and of course black has nothing
better to do than to play this
immediately and this is a movie you
could basically play automatically
because walking around and taking the
pawn first of all that violates rule one
and that's just madness that's that
takes 800 years
but the critical position occurs after a
takes b5 check
this is the important position
pause the video and see if you can
figure out where the black king should
go should it take the pawn should go
somewhere else and why this is a tricky
question in my opinion one of the
loveliest themes in pawn races so
really put some thought into it
okay
so i think the tendency in like a blitz
game would be to play king takes b5
right what happens here well let's
follow this line f5 a3 f6 a2f7 a1 queen
simultaneous promotion and if anybody's
playing for a win it's white because
white's going to be the one to win the h
pawn
that does not look appetizing
so we have to consider the alternatives
now
i hope that you were able to
conceptualize
an interesting idea right what if we
tried to use our king to somehow
interfere with the progress of the
f-pawn well that might seem like madness
because you're going to leave the b-pawn
alive and then white is going to get
trousers and beating trousers is like
beating a full house in pokemon very few
things beat trousers but here black can
beat trousers by applying rule four the
correct move
is king d6
now what the heck let's unpack this
let's unpack this first of all let's
understand what happens if white takes
the pun and again i'm not going to make
the moves on the board just yet to
promote visualization practice let's
follow the line king takes g6 right a4
f5 this is the fun part a3 f6 a2 f7 wait
a minute we stepped into the checking
zone we stepped into the checking zone
of the pawn this is the worst move in
the position
no it's not and this is where rule four
often supersedes supersedes rule two
because in that position after f7 you
can force white's king into the checking
zone by bringing your king back to e7
covering the promotion square white's
king is forced to move to g7 and notice
that then the king is in the checking
zone of the black gang brilliant
let's now play the moves on the board
and uh you'll be able to fully convince
yourself of this so king takes g6 a2 now
uh a4
importantly if white pushes the b-pawn
that accelerates white's demise because
black plays a3 and the king is able to
stop the pawn so white cannot afford to
spend any time
on the pro on the motion of the b-pun
that is why the trousers here are
ineffective because the king is able to
do its job in fact the king is such a
beast here it's multitasking right it's
stopping the b-pawn and it's assisting
in forcing white's king into the
checking zone so white has no choice but
to play f5 or java actually resigned
after king d6 because he already
understood that fedex saw the idea so
a2f7 and this is the critical moment
black drops back to e7
now b6 is too slow
white has to play king g7 to prepare
promotion but what black promotes and
we've gotten the white king into the
checking zone
and this is just amazingly paradoxical
you don't recapture the pawn and only
king d6 works the reason king d7 does
not work
is because white is actually able to
stop black's pawn and the bonus rule is
going to uh explore this exact scenario
so
in this case white is in the square and
white is able to stop the pawn and
actually black is the one who's got to
be careful here the game should end in a
draw
now
the application of rule 4 can actually
lead to some absolutely incredible ideas
some really really cool ideas and
this position i think epitomizes that
this is from a blitz game that i played
against the iranian gm amin tabitabai
about a year and a half ago and when i
played this game i didn't think anything
of it but then when i started analyzing
i was like oh my goodness this is
ridiculous this is why i love chess it's
just a random blitz game you can produce
something that's worth sharing and and
worth learning from and analyzing
now
take a moment to again adjust your eyes
to the position you should almost
immediately start to understand how a
pawn race crystallizes here right well
white already has a pass up on the c
pawn so we're going to move the king and
start pushing the c bonds somewhere
black is going to have to take h3
and then if you are patient then you
should be able to see the black has two
ways to create a pass pawn black can
take g4
and then step back with the king or push
the f pawn or after king takes h3 black
can immediately push the f pawn to f5
with a simple pawn breakthrough and if g
takes f5 black pushes the g pawn that in
some situations might be more efficient
so you should keep both of those options
in mind and of course the question is
where should we step away with our king
and uh here you actually have to apply
both rule 2 and rule 4 which makes this
really cool now when i gave this
position to some of my highest rated
students they almost all
kind of uniformly gave the same answer
and
at this point you can pause the video
and you can think this is probably the
hardest position just sort of concept
wise and and just solution wise that
i've shared so far in these end game
videos so you know don't beat yourself
up if you don't get it but i would still
encourage you to take a stab at it
so
almost everybody i've given this
position to
they
play the move king d4 which and i think
there is a just a huge mental pull to
play this move because this approaches
the black pawns and what could be more
natural
than
trying to use your king either as a
roadblock or this is this seems to be
the move to make right it's just so
natural to get the king into the center
and yet all of that is an illusion
because if you actually apply the rules
you should be able to see that this move
actually is the opposite of natural why
because the moment king d4 is played i
see that the king has entered the
checking zone of the g pawn which
doesn't immediately disqualify it but
makes me very skeptical and if we follow
the line and i played king d4 in the
game after king takes h3 c4
if king takes g4 this is uh
wrong because after c5 king f5 black
white is able to use the second clause
of
rule 4 and bring the king up to d5 no no
no you're not going anywhere and white
promotes with check because now the
black king is in the checking zone of
widespawn which is kind of cool
okay
excuse me
so that's not going to cut it but that's
not the most efficient way of creating a
passer and black plays the move f5 this
is what happened in the game
and after g takes f5 which is the
correct move that's not what i played
we have his case of simultaneous
promotion black promotes with check and
i plug this position into table bases
yes it is winning for white technically
this position is winning for white
however the actual win is incredibly
difficult and these positions occur very
frequently in chess practice and i'd say
it's about 50 50. sometimes white is
able to win sometimes it's a draw but
regardless the process takes forever and
this is not what we want to do we have a
much more convincing win now in the game
i decided to play c5 we only had a
couple of seconds left so i'll forgive
myself and amazingly my opponent messed
up
and again the question is should black
go f4 or should black go f takes g4
well
by now you should be a pro in
identifying checking zone you should see
that when white promotes
the checking zone is the c8h3 diagonal
and just like in that example from the
world youth chess championship it's
critically important to leave on the
board do not take unnecessary puns
here's an application of rule one my
opponent took on g4 this opened up the
checking zone and after c8 queen equals
check i was able to win the game
instead the move f4 actually led to an
advantageous position for black
because here we have simultaneous
promotion there's no longer a check
black promotes with f1 and black is much
closer to white spawn and white is the
one who would have had to grovel
essentially
for a draw so see how many mistakes were
made in such an ostensibly simple
position welcome to pawn end games now
let's go all the way all the way back
let's rewind
so
what can we glean from the move king d4
well the first thing we can clean is
that the positive part of this move is
that our king gets into position
where if black's king tries to make a
run for it and stop white spawn white is
able to stop the king with king d5 so
that that aspect of this move is good
but what's bad about it is that it puts
the king into the checking zone of the
pawn so can we make a move
that also keeps the king in close
proximity to the pawn while getting away
from the checking zone well what that
yields might seem so counter-intuitive
too so unnatural this cannot be the move
and it is king b4 is the correct move
as far away as possible from black
spawns
and watch king takes h3 you go c4
now after f5 we're actually going to use
rule three this is what i love about
this example all of the rules are
applied we have simultaneous promotion
recognize this i json files check
check
trade
promote boom
that is refuted and this is
the crops crux of the position because
previously remember the king was on d4
now this is not a check
and if black takes on g4 you might say
whoa
when our king was on d4 we had king d5
but remember the chess board is
symmetrical in many ways you can do
things from one side or you can do it
from the other side as a matter of fact
white can even get away with playing c6
first after king e6 king c5
just store this this position in your
mind this is a very important
construction where the pawn is
controlling one square the white king is
controlling another and after g4 it is
critical not to play c7 this would
uh lose everything after king d7 king v6
king c8 very commonly missed so note
this down as well black gets behind the
pawn in front of the pawn i guess the
key is to play king b6 first after g3
you play c7
king d7 king b7 black's king is in the
checking zone c8 equals queen is a check
and white wins in brilliant brilliant
manner now would you look at that king
b4 the only move that wins the game
convincingly and again if you follow
sort of general endgame principles which
say that you should get your king toward
the center well you'll play king d4 or
maybe even king d3 now the problem with
king d3 as i already explained is that
black is able to stop the pawn and
actually just win the game
so
that's why i'm doing a video on pawn
races because pawn races literally have
their own rules and you have to follow
those rules in order to find the correct
approach and that then leads us to the
final rule of pawn races and a kind of
bonus rule as well
which says
drum roll please as i
project both of these onto the screen
let's see if i can fit them on
yeah
so uh rule five says
prepare for pawn races by pushing the
prospective passer beforehand you might
recognize that terminology from the
previous video the bonus rule says you
don't always have to participate in upon
race and you'll understand what both of
those things mean in our final example
uh this video going a little bit longer
than i expected
and wanted to so if you're still
listening uh thank you so much and uh i
promise this is the last example but
this will be worth it this is a an
example that's gonna knock your socks
off this is from a speedrun game that i
played a couple of months ago
and uh again when i played it i didn't
think much of it but then when i
analyzed it i was like wow this end game
is amazing and there are other parts of
this end game that i've left out that i
might analyze in subsequent videos now
it's white to play
i am playing black this was a very
competitive game my opponent played
amazing and she reached this end game
where a pawn race again may not seem to
be a bygone conclusion but if you look
more carefully you'll see that it is
because black is a three-on-two majority
and black's easiest way to create a
passer is of course to push the c pawn
to c4 with the check right
okay
white already has a passer so already in
your mind you could see a pawn race
forming or black goes toward the king
side king e5 and takes this pawn on h3
white on the other hand
uh travels to the other side of the
board and takes one the a pawn and has
the pass tape on so the tactical
potential of this is tremendous you can
already envision situations where one
side promotes and prevents the other
side from promoting so it's going to be
incredibly important to win this pawn
race
now
what do you do
well
again
prepare for pawn races by pushing the
prospective passer beforehand we've now
taken all a step all the way back we
started from pawn races
um and picking up your opponent's pawns
we took a big step back now we're
talking about the time when you've
identified that upon race is likely well
how do you prepare for it well what you
need to do is you need to say well which
pawn is going to be the participant in
the pawn race what's probably going to
be the a pawn
and the natural thing to do if you can
afford it is to push that pawn up as far
as you can so that when the pawn race
actually occurs you will be as well
equipped to win it as possible because
every tempo is critical
and hopefully that information alone
gives you what you need in order to find
the correct move for white pause the
video final
question
how should white go about trying to save
the game
now first let's examine what my opponent
did
my opponent played the move h4 which may
seem like a natural move but in fact
it's counterproductive it gets this pawn
closer to the black king
and after c4 check
bc4 bc4 the pawn race is won by black if
you want you can pause and calculate
this out but i'll cut you a little bit
of slack now king e3 doesn't
substantively change anything here black
uses the decoy method to distract the
white king and you get exactly the same
scenario this exact position can be
reached after king c3 king e4 as well
and to dovetail this back to our first
example again white takes the pawn first
but don't be fooled by that keep
calculating and you will see that after
king b16 g3 we have the classic scenario
where black promotes first and prevents
white from promoting and gets the queen
back toward a8 so black wins the game
but instead of h4
push the perspective passer a4 only move
drawing the game
and here's the thing
after b takes a4 b takes a4 first let's
consider what happens if black does the
same thing well just mathematically
speaking we have the same position
except white's pawn is two square
squares forward uh so you've saved one
tempo
and that means the game ends in a draw
and in fact it's black who has to be
very careful this is where you have to
violate rule number two you actually
have to put the king in the checking
zone but we already discussed this
scenario the only reason you do that is
because if the king was on g3 here the
queen would be covering h1 as it stands
black reaches uh an already familiar
theoretical position
uh so calculation is more important than
everything right you can't just blindly
follow these rules these rules are meant
to assist in your calculation the
calculation is still king
okay
now um
if we rewind a little bit
black can also participate in this game
two can play at that game so black is
head
you're gonna push the a pawn i'm gonna
push the h pawn i'm gonna do exactly the
same thing and prepare myself for the
race
and after f5 king e5 king c4
king takes f5 king takes c5 king f4 if
you think about it we have the original
situation both sides have made one extra
move which would seem to mean that white
loses the pawn race as we already know
but this is where the bonus rule comes
into effect which says that you don't
always have to participate in a pawn
race very often if you've identified and
calculated upon race and figured out
that you're losing one last ditch idea
could be to follow the opposing king
toward the pawn that it's going to
capture and particularly this works if
this is a corner pawn try to lock that
king up
what does that mean in the context of
this position well the drawing move here
shockingly is king d4
after kg3 king e3 hopefully you're
familiar with his general type of idea
now it may seem
and
you hopefully know this from the
previous video that black who has the
outside passer has an easy win because
black is the extra move h3
white's king is forced to release the
black king from jail
and then using the outside pass bond
method black just walks over and picks
up the a pawn but corner pawns are
special right corner puns don't follow
the same rules as other pawns in order
to win an endgame of the corner pawn the
conditions are a lot stricter if the
white king reaches c2
that's already a draw and that's exactly
what happens black just doesn't have
enough time white's king turns into
usain bolt all of a sudden and his able
despite seemingly not having enough time
to reach c1 by the narrowest of margins
king c1 and white draws the game and
hopefully you know that this is a draw
even though uh black has quote unquote
opposition this is a very famous drawing
position because if black's king steps
away then why does king b1 otherwise
white keeps the black king contained and
uh ultimately stalemates it with king c2
so you start by following rule number
five and then you also follow the bonus
rule and you might ask wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute why can't
you follow the bonus rule
here why can't you go king d4
why can't you do this well the reason
you can't do this here has to do
with the move a5 a4 and again black
prepares for the race
black preemptively pushes the pawn to a4
and it's because it's black pawn on a4
not white spawn that black ultimately
wins watch a3 king h3
you know the drill king f3h4 king f2 now
white's king is no longer usain bolt
black's pawn is already further off
further
in this position black team would have
been on a4 if black had captured a pawn
on a4 black played king a3 and white
played king c2 white was in time but
here black plays king b2 it's all about
the tempe and the red carpet is unrolled
black wins the game
and so that is why you have to start by
following rule five and only if black
follows it two do you divert to the
bonus roll and trail the black king and
lock it up and
miraculously make the draw the move a4
to me it's just such a nice illustration
of what makes end games so beautiful
they're so concrete and you can see the
logic so clearly i think a lot of middle
games
are complex they're not always subject
to clear logic but so many of these pun
end games are you can just trace the
logic of how things work even if the
machinery is very complex and that
ladies and gentlemen concludes our five
rules for pawn races let me project all
of them on the screen at once so you can
take them down in your notes if you want
to
and i'm a big uh proponent of writing
things down here they are
rule one do not capture unnecessary
pawns find the most efficient method
rule two do not step away into the
checking zone of your opponent's passer
see
when your opponent queen says pass pawn
what diagonal is the queen going to be
checking on rule 3 simultaneous
promotion does not equal draw those
queen end games can be very complicated
in their own right look for skewers rule
4 use your king to force the enemy king
into the checking zone or to prevent the
enemy king from stopping your pawn
remember king b4 in my game against amin
rule 5 prepare for pawn races and by the
way uh st
abiding by rule four often entails
violating rule two remember that white
kind of had to step into the checking
zone but it was only in order to drag
black's king into the checking zone and
it's the fact that white promoted first
that justified that rule five prepare
for pawn races by pushing the
prospective passer beforehand and this
is what you're looking at right now the
move a4 sets white up for the pawn race
because he's going to take she's going
to take a5 and the bonus roll you don't
always have to participate in a pawn
race sometimes you can say no and
sometimes you can actually walk your
king back and either stop your
opponent's passer or lock the king into
the corner kind of like white could have
done in this game
this is by no means comprehensive but i
hope that these five rules and the bonus
rule kind of help you frame pawn races
sometimes you just lose them no matter
how many rules you follow your opponent
is just faster and there's nothing you
can do about it but in many cases as
hopefully i was able to convince you
following these rules and applying savvy
actually enables you to turn some of
these races around
and to save some improbable positions so
the second video is in the books ladies
and gentlemen you're now intimately
familiar with two concepts of pawn end
games we've talked about past pawns
we've talked about pawn races and in the
next video we will talk about pawn
breakthroughs the next video is gonna be
a little bit shorter but no less
essential thank you so much for watching
i know this was long hope you enjoyed
and uh i'm greatly enjoying uh recording
this series can't wait for the next
video i'll see you then happy end game
play goodbye
[Music]
you